yes brother
alikum I would like to know about
the while traveling brother a question
that while traveling can we offer Salah
what is Salah mean shortening of the
prayers when you're traveling you have
gone away from your hometown the
distance is there some say 80 km some
say 90 km little bit difference is there
but when you're traveling away from your
home at that time you should offer KAS
Salah KAS Salah means all the four Rats
of
Z as well as is should be short into two
raat that's an advice given we find
theith unless you're offering in jamama
if you're praying Salah in jam and the
IM is a m he's not a traveler and if
he's offering four of
Z then when you're joining that jamat
you should offer four but if you're
praying
individually or if you made a group only
of Travelers then for Z ass and for Isa
you should offer two
you should not offer four you should
offer two unless you're joining a group
which is offering four raat who is not a
traveler and secondly you have even
option of joining doing jamama doing Jam
is not F it's not must is Mu you can
join your Z and Salah together and you
can join your M and is Salah together so
anytime from the start of Z Salah timing
till the end of Salah timing you can
join both together so you have got
freedom because you're traveling in a
place you may not be having that
convenience you may be staying in a
place which may not be having facility
so you can offer your zor and ass
together joining anytime from the start
of Z Salah When you pray at the Zar time
you're bringing your ass Salah forward
so you're eting two raat and two raat
and together when you're praying time
you delaying your Z Salah both are
permitted similarly in M time and Isa
time you can pray M and Isa together
from the start of MB time till the end
of Isa time if you m time both together
you're bringing forward your is Salah if
you're praying at afterward Isa time you
delaying your M Sal both allowed some
schools of thought say no only you can
delay you cannot bring It Forward you
get both these examples in Hajj when you
go for one of the AR that have to join
together and when you you praying your Z
and together you're bringing forward
your and when you leave theat that time
you don't pray when you come to M at ISA
time you join your M and Isa so we have
both the examples in h so both are
permitted depending upon the convenience
so KAS if you're praying alone is a
requirement all four have been done too
and your F Salah Remains Two and your M
Salah remains three and during traveling
you should not offer any Sunnah except
the Sunnah of the F the F toah before
the
farat is a very important Sunnah which
while traveling that you should not miss
as fast possible all the other Sun you
need not pray shouldn't pray if you want
to offer as much of n no problem problem
hope that answer the question